martin perez pitching
teen had the up and down spring training
through the ball well but did have some
walk issues at
one start where he walked five rosarina
is off to a hot start four for eleven
made a spectacular diving grab in right
field last night and a 1-2
and right through there to freeze him
and strike him out
two down well it's almost like he caught
him by surprise with that fastball like
he was expecting him to waste the pitch
arroyo has one hit and three bats off
him it's a home run
shot bratz a fair ball over the leaping
padlo down the line extra bases
hugging the doorway and he is into
second base with a double and a great
start for christian arroyo
and down to third moves arroyo one
sitting on third base with two down now
for bogey who was
unbelievable last night that one skips
away
here comes the run and the red sox
leading one to nothing
that one just ate zunino alive and the
socks are on the board
he threw that one about 53 feet i have
no
idea what this was it was supposed to be
a curveball
or you take him any way you can get him
when you're facing a guy like glasshouse
kevin padlow about to make his major
league debut as
a hitter he's in a quick hole there's
the o2
and down he goes that was good morning
good afternoon and good night
that's a rude greeting from martine
after a single to cenino a four pitch
walk to yandy diaz
but the tying and go ahead runners
aboard and now here is randy a rosarina
one and two to a rosarena swinging a
line drive base hit towards the gap in
left center
charging now is cordero holding zanino
at third as the throw comes in rolls
away
from marvin gonzalez but he runs over
and picks it up a base hit for a
rosarena
and the rays have loaded the bases
manuel margot who lined the left is only
time
right now swinging a slow ground ball to
the right side it trickles in base hit
right field
zamino scores diaz heads for home
renfro's throw
not in time two-run single manuel margot
and the rays take a 2-1 lead
so that puts two on with two that brings
the bar when gonzalez is struck out
looking in the second inning
xander bogart's down to third that sucks
have come in
and then runner's going to get out of
second base on a pitch down into the
dirt so
vazquez picks up second red sox have
already scored a run on a wild pitch
tonight oh he took off early didn't he
he was standing on second base oh my
goodness
all glassdoll had to do is step off of
glass now
that's not even looking at it and that
is strike three called at 98
leaving two
and if he's gonna come six today he's
probably gonna have to have a pretty
quick inning here in the fifth
he'll be facing eight nine one renfro
cordero and arroyo
the first pitch here in the bottom of
the fifth renfro pops it up
[Music]
foul ball now and diaz makes the catch
and that's a strike to go down to first
to complete it
cordero is out number two
three two pitch swung out and missed
strike three bloom away with a fastball
and a pump of the fist by glass now and
a banging of the bat down into the
ground
by arroyo and tyler glassnow with a
1-2-3
fifth inning and austin bryce the
right-hander were
end of the fray here against adamus
and a high high fly ball deep to left
field backing up cordero at the wall
it'll be off the monster runner will be
held up at third bases to play back at
first
and he is going to be cut down trying to
get back in
how can that happen how could you hit a
ball this high
in that far and be caught picked off
first base he thought he had it all
and he was not running down that first
base line hard he's halfway between
first and second that should never
happen so let's see if wendell can get
something going here pinch hit wise
which there's a base hit wendell comes
through to score loud
and the rays tack on the run boy what a
big pinch hit that is for joy wendell
with a two strike two out pitch hick
gives the raise a three to one lead
and the red sox have runners at first
and third with two down and vasquez
coming up
[Music]
he struck him out vasquez goes down
and the red sox rally is thwarted last
night's last one a 98
watch his reaction after he gets the out
he's in some trouble here they hit
batsman
a walk and now margot has gone one for
three and has the key hit in the game
a two-run single in the third courtesy
of mr chris sale high fly ball left
field that one crank backing up is
cordero fell
for the wall leaps up and it's in the
glove
here comes a run attempting to score
cordero going back up against the wall
out there
oh no no no about this i i heard tin
and then the glove this is a huge play
but i think it hit the wall first
let's see yeah i did hit the wall first
and then into the glove you could hear
the wall
you can hear it hit the wall it wasn't
the glove hitting the wall or was it
let's see what they say here whoa daddy
caught it right
how about that and that ends the inning
behind in there against glass now they
didn't get the game out of hand
they feel well let's let's take a shot
at the bullpen now
jd martinez hasn't had many quiet ones
yet but
he's over three so far tonight
slaps that one the other way driving
back the right fielder it's over the
head
of a rosarina berdugo
rounding third and he is in to slide and
score
another extra base hit from martinez
it's a one-run game
you know everything in the air to right
you expect the rosarina to catch but not
this time
that ball just took off on him and his
rawfield evers he's one for three with a
single
going to head toward the alley but run
down by margot
and jd martinez is going to be doubled
off
jd martinez with a major base running
mistake and did not realize how many
outs there were
or thought that ball was going to drop
into the alley
and winds up getting doubled up and that
ends the inning
christian in this one is grounded out to
third walked and struck
out i fly ball
that one way back there watch it go it
is gone
and this game is tied oh
he got all of it and a red sox tied 3-3
in the ninth oh big 02 mistake that time
by castillo
leaves one out over the plate and
baskets
absolutely crushes this ball and so the
winning run is at third
and they are not going to intentionally
walk at least to start jd martinez he's
got a chance to win it he's not running
shot oh terrific play there throw on to
first base and in time
on a diving effort by adamus
so the red sox cannot bring that run in
runner at second base is brandon loud a
face
willie adams one of the heroes of the
10th
and anseliner up the left side back
toward the corner
that's going to score the round extra
basis for adamas
and the reigns will take the lead here
in the 11th inning
springs for the first one
and a liner and a basin in the left
field giving chase
and here comes xander he is in to score
and this game is tied again
and that didn't take long bring the
infield in
put the ball in play trying to make
something happen here
[Music]
in the middle is going to be out at
first
enzo nino so the rays take the lead
it's a 5-4 ball game now
so the tying run is 90 feet away the
winning run is at second base
and what do you want to do do you want
to pitch to jd martinez
or do you want to pitch the xander
bogots in this situation
that one's driven to right field rosa
rania backing up back it up it's over
his head
and it's over his head and the red sox
are going to win the game
two-run score boston wins
boy is that a fitting end to this one
wow